I'm Nick Montfort professor of digital
media here at MIT in comparative media
studies and writing along with Mary
Fuller from literature
I'm very glad to be hosting Lou it the
visiting scholar we all know as Lupe
Fiasco AKA wasalu yaco through the
Martin Luther King Jr Jr fellowship
program
my thanks to the Institute community and
Equity office for bringing Lupe Fiasco
to MIT this year
and for the other good work they do on
campus
once in a while recently people have
been asking me
wait
what's Lupe Fiasco doing at MIT
it turns out
they're not asking this because they're
skeptical about Lupe Fiasco
they're skeptical of MIT
well
our Institute is a very distributed
place with a lot going on it may
surprise some of you to learn we have a
rich curriculum for undergraduates in
media studies writing and literature
and there's more on offer in the school
of humanities arts and social sciences
while technical studies are certainly
the focus MIT has the first architecture
school in the United States as well as
the MIT media lab a program in art
culture and technology and another in
women's and gender studies the Sloan
school and more
I know many of you have come from off
campus
you made it through the Eventbrite
registration system
and it's not as bad as Ticketmaster I
know but
um you found your way to the building on
this rainy night got into it got through
part of the MIT maze to this numbered
room
now even though MIT has had to limit
Public Access because of the pandemic
we're very glad the people in the
community come to join us for events
like this
I look forward to Lupe Fiasco's talk and
hearing your questions for our speaker
because I know that what you have to say
and what you have to ask will help me
learn
as of tomorrow December 1st the MIT
campus will be opening up further and it
will be easier to visit us on campus
you'll find a newly opened MIT Museum
the MIT press bookstore the art shown at
the list Visual Arts Center a public art
collection that includes many sculptures
Outdoors the MIT libraries and a new
Welcome Center
if you like rap
I suspect
some of you do
you should know that in this room in
2017 thanks to the Center for art
Science and Technology Professor
Michelle DeGraff and I hosted Haitian
poet singer songwriter rapper Bic
Roosevelt sayant who gave a public
concert
just two months ago bridgeside Cipher
brought a live band and welcomed rappers
from the community to an outdoor area
near the Kendall MIT t-stop thanks to
mit's open space initiative which had
brought rappers to the space before that
to those who made the trip to be here
tonight
thank you for coming welcome to MIT and
please consider yourselves welcome to
visit us again
now what can be said to introduce
tonight's speaker
MIT visiting scholar Grammy
award-winning rapper record producer
entrepreneur activist a founder of the
Society of spoken art
a founder of the Societe International
de ER
with Eight studio albums that run from
Food and Liquor
to this year's drill music in Zion
colleagues
neighbors friends
here's Lupe Fiasco
[Applause]
I got to appreciate it
hello thank you DACA T appreciate the uh
the introduction
um I don't know if Mary Fuller is here
as well hey Mary full appreciate you
both uh as well as uh uh Dr Fox
um IR
um appreciate you as well
um my family here at MIT uh as well as
Sophia the literature Department admits
what's happening
um compared to me to studies the entire
shafts but as well as uh the mecca The
Hobby Shop
the sailing Pavilion
uh
Verdes
appreciate you all
um what I'm trying to do is keep this
very casual
um and what I'm doing is a little bit of
what the class is the class I'll be
teaching
um and we're trying to run like a little
mock beta version of that in here
um so relax yourselves let your concert
should be free you're not roll them with
thugs or the MIT really
um not thugs but you know
rappers
um
so it's an introduction we'll we'll Pace
it out there'll be
um
a little column response you have some
duties if you have a piece of paper a
pen or some type of writing material or
even something digital I'm going to need
that very soon
so do that
but let's get into it rap theory and
practice and introduction
to what I'm doing here at MIT
and what the plans are for the future
but first I have to introduce myself
see if this works there we go
that's me
that's my high school yearbook picture
right I think I was 17.
and I think as you can see I clearly
invested into
sorry clearly invested into
um this thing so that's my high school
talent show
I'm going to skip forward
to
that picture
that is Spring Fest 2015 here at MIT
so that's me performing
at MIT
and then we'll do another jump
that is me
a couple months ago
in Central Park New York Performing as
MIT
um
rap has always been a Scholastic Pursuit
for me
I learned how to rap in school
that's where I hone my skill sets
that's why I learned everything that I
do now it's always been in a school
environment
so this isn't foreign right this isn't
anything completely novel
um
and the proof is kind of in the pudding
so it is for me this makes perfect sense
that I would be back in a school
environment teaching
because I learned this craft at a school
you know at my high school
you know
um
we'll we'll belay the biography and
other things and we'll get right into
the meat of the matter
what are
slash
is wraps slash wrap
acronyms only
right so this is your job now
you got about a few minutes
acronyms are you take the word
I'm very fundamental
you take each letter in the word
and then you put another you make a
letter out of that a word out of that
letter
that describes
the word the original word The Source
word
let me know you got a good one like a
real good one
and then you can like stand up and
blurt it out
and disciplined way but think think
through it think about it deeply I want
you to reflect
aggressively
I want you to penetrate
subconsciously
and really think about it
what are wraps what is rap
all right
give it like another minute to Stew
doc you find you this is familiar
to you.com T
hey guys welcome
it needs to come up with an acronym for
rap or wraps you can pick
not now
whoa there cowboy
all right that's eight okay who we got
that's how we putting people on blast
come on
uh riffs and poetry riffs and poetry
okay
let's let's do a whole
okay
it's uh do let's do the new comma
always I mean the thing is mine was
Rhythm and poetry I'm trying to uh okay
so you're buying Styles already I see
um doc I.T
okay
Rhythm and people
rooted autobiographies pronounced uh-huh
nice
Cowboy what's up
okay uh realization and passion
realizations and Passions
which is randomly Point realist
perspectives real ass perspectives okay
it's a lot of ass in the room I don't
know why
I'm biasing to ask I will take it right
Rhymes in facing Rhymes and pacing yeah
rhythmic access to people's Souls ridden
the access to people's Souls Jesus
Christ
utterly beautiful
it's even meaningful
um
very Fuller
ton four months righteous artistic
performance
cheesy
D1
my brother
hey anybody else want to throw their
last everybody's welcome
running after purpose I like that
shout out
well mine was kind of already said I
said right Rhymes and peace
and pace
yep mine is the base b-a-s-s beats and
stories fun you know that's not wraps
right
do you play the bass is that why you did
that no okay all right all right that's
unaccepted just FYI
um
we enjoy it in country
artistic power and Style hey rare
artistic power and style okay
cowboy
did you have another one
no
okay
I think about this
constantly
and I'm constantly revising
and setting new rules about how the
acronym should be developed
the original acronym that we started at
Sosa and built Sosa Society spoken upon
uh was rhetorical
anthropological philosophical structures
and then we created an entire curriculum
about investigating that particular
definition
of rap
the most recent one that I had
was relationships associations parallels
and well I can't say the other I can't
say that we'll leave it at that because
that's that's come true later
well I was here
um maybe
a month ago I came up with these
recognizing analogous patterns
maybe reconciling adversarial patterning
and just goes on and on and on and on
right constantly revising constantly
being dynamic
right because that's what rap deserves
it deserves constant attention constant
Focus constant alteration
right constant changing in the face of
new Ventures new places new spaces new
ideas new generations
as they take it
and make it what it means to be for them
right but it's also really really sexy I
think
right this idea of
defining it by its own structures what's
already there
right not trying to go too far out and
make it something that it's not like can
we Define it within its own terms
and then what is the process to get to
that
right what happens when you do that
to your name
right what do you happen what happens
when you do that with your job
description
what do you have what happens when you
do that to your belief systems
what is the mechanisms and the tools and
what changes
right
so it's meant to constantly be defined
and then dug into right
what does it mean to reconcile
adversaries
what does it mean to be righteously
aggressive
what does it mean to to base you know
to be based
cook and dance
so
shapes and details right
sometimes we get this confused we talk
about rap right I like to keep things
very fundamental very simple very basic
we can get complex later
we're already complex that's the problem
too complex
right we need to
dumb it down
going over people's head
s
um
I like to do it this is very to me this
is very clean right
the metaphor or the analogy would be
bodybuilders
right
if you want to become a bodybuilder
first thing you have to do
is get into
shape
right just a general shape a generable
general workable
shape
right big exercises just do some squats
let's do some bench presses right just
big exercises
then as you start to want to get your
pro card
you got to get into the details
right a little five pound little joints
once you just do this little thing right
here to get this little part right here
to just pop a little bit right
get into these details
right shapes and details
right big big ideas
big big Concepts
then how do we execute through those
Concepts
right how do we filter through and come
and get the details
right and they play off each other yeah
I have both you can't just be super
duper detail-oriented with no shape
right you can't just have shape all the
time with no details right if you want
to be
subjectively good but even objectively
good
right because this is happening whether
you want to or not
you're playing with shapes Primal big
primes and playing with these little
small things shapes and details to keep
it really basic
so get a little bit more
precise
is my favorite word in rap
she knows where it was in rap
because I put it there
yeah use it all the time micro decisions
right your details
we'll get into what these are
a couple
micro decisions May consist of
stretching
or extending specific vowels
in words
to achieve or regulate certain tones
moods or temporalities
right
so you have to do all of this all you
need is I need this punch line I need
this I need that like no I need you to
put a little more stress
lay on that oh
so it goes oh
did you behold
what I did
right I need that ah and what to be very
quick
right so behold feels like this
how do you do that in words well you
have to say oh
[Music]
right
seems silly
it won me a Grammy
right
[Music]
right seems Seems like Ah that's nothing
so millions of Records
Millions
made millions of dollars
cars jewelry it's ridiculous
what you could do
with stretching vowels right
one simple tool that one simple micro
decision
right and you can just play with it all
day you sit with words and say I'ma take
take the word itself micro decision
my Crow
decision
right well I'm gonna do my growth
decision
okay all right I got I got my
I got what I want to put my stresses on
my vowels
right and now I'm gonna go write this
verse
right I already got the shape I already
know what I'm gonna talk about but now
let me get into these details work on
these micro decisions and there's more
there's a list but we don't have time
macro decisions
big [ __ ]
right big old things
Big Ideas
right big shapes
we're going to dive deep into this this
next one
one of the best
macro decisions and what I've been
studying here on the research side since
I've been at MIT
has been studying
surprise
right
surprise is one of the fundamental
Primal pieces
of life
this is rap of life
[ __ ] right
I can make the claim that everything you
learned
was by surprise
in one way or another
right it's kind of crept up on you
right
you didn't know before you know it now
what's the mechanism to get it
to Traverse that distance that Gap
it's probably surprise
right
let's go deep you ready ready to get
deep ready to go to class check this out
that's right I read white papers and I
cite
surprises
not only influence individuals attention
learning memory attitudes and behavior
they can also have larger scale
social influences this is because people
seem to be interested in Sharing
Surprises with others
who shared the meme today
we shared the video today
right what's the word I give you two
dollars not in real money
but in Lupe dollars
if you tell me what's one of the
one of the phrases that we always see
one of the common phrases that we see
and videos being posted on social media
huh
viral yeah yeah but we don't really see
this is this is viral like what do we
see in the comment section in the
description
watch till the end
right or
wait for it
what is that
wait for it right
share that
right it goes viral
because you see that one thing and then
you like she's like
buddy right
you know that one look at you surprised
he's like she was surprised that I knew
that didn't you
but it's right you're laughing how many
times did you watch it
yeah
bye
bye right I didn't expect that little
girl to do that
I watched that [ __ ] so many times it was
crazy
right and there's others
right
stories with surprising elements tend to
degrade and change less as they are past
the law than stories without surprising
elements
a surprising
right
how does Lupe Fiasco persist
this long people can't believe it right
I don't talk about sex I don't talk
about guns
I kind of do but I don't know
I want to really bad
it's just littered with little surprises
little land mines of whoa
bars that you don't get until like five
years later
when you're watching some random cartoon
from Turkmenistan maybe I'm like
oh oh
right
they sustain they're stable
right ain't that what we want in careers
right
isn't that kind of the essence
of longevity right it doesn't degrade
how do we get to that maybe do surprise
here's another one I got them all day
surprising information has been shown to
impact what we remember
and to facilitate transfer of learning
strategies
inducing an uncertain mood like surprise
has been found to lead to more systemic
processing which might Aid learning
what does rap do all day
you know how much [ __ ] I learned from
rap
I learned how about Rolexes from rat
did you know Rolex is a 501c3
that's a non-for-profit
I didn't learn that from rap but
surprise
right
I bring it up not lightly
rap teaches a lot
is one of the most ultimate teaching
tools teaches you how to dance
teaches you how to dress
es you how to talk teaches you how to
walk teaches you how to think
it's ridiculously
ridiculously capable
right
you can also teach how to kill people
teach you how to sell drugs teach you
how to die teach you how to go to prison
right teach you how to survive in prison
get your job it could teach politics
right teach you to vote for
it's a teaching tool
right
how many people intentionally use it
as that
how many people just do it for fun how
many rappers in it
for fun right
for money
money and fun there we go right
he didn't say teaching
because unfortunately most rappers don't
know how
right
we live by phrase that Sosa
that rappers know
how to do it
but they don't know what they're doing
because rap was never formally trained
it was never put into an institution
and all of these things like this
you didn't have to take a test
to become a rapper
your test was doesn't work at your strip
club
which is the Atlanta formula
for real
does it work at a strip club
that is the test for rep
I don't care how you got there but can
you have that effect
can you teach strippers to dance
right that has its place
right but rap has so much potential
right
so if you come to the class
you're going to be doing this [ __ ]
We're not gonna have we're gonna have
some fun I'm gonna make it fun
but we're gonna be doing this that's a
warning
to the students out there
who thought she was going to be in here
making strip club music with Lupe Fiasco
we're going to be reading white papers
about surprisal foreign
you how to do that with intention
so you can really
elevate
the power of The Craft
right and really use it as a teaching
thing
because if you do it successfully guess
what my man's
you'll make more money and have more fun
because you'll have more followers
because more things will go viral
you create deeper
relationships
associations parallels and surprises
right
here's another one
surprise we still surprised surprises
evoked just to give you a little sense
of what it is
right that stuff was kind of descriptive
this is what it is how it works surprise
is evoked by unexpected schema
discrepant events
and it's intense intensity is determined
by the degree of the scheme of
discrepancy right how far off is this
from normality for you
right it's how big the surprise is
unexpected events cause an automatic
Interruption of ongoing mental processes
that is followed by an intentional shift
and intentional binding to the events
it's like oh what is that oh what's that
right
which is often followed by causal
and other event analysis processes
and by schema revision
schemas are kind of World Views kind of
conceptual frames cognitively how you
view the world how you pursue through it
right and run after purpose
right you do that in certain ways in
certain paths based on what your kind of
fundamental schemas are these schemas
are constantly being changed as you
interface with different types of
information and different types of
experiences people's places
right
so that's why you have to be careful
what you listen to
be careful who you listen to and where
you go
because unconsciously
your brain is changing
right and not necessarily your neurons
or like neuroplasticity and stuff like
that that happens but on the front end
just the way
that your schemas change
right
Story Time repetition break plot
structure
here's a tool of how you can use
surprise let's bring it back down to
earth let's come out to white papers
right let's take to the streets
are you in a gang
you
you in a gang
no okay
which is actually infused in the game
you got a lot of blue there I'm just
making sure
[Laughter]
nice sweater I like it don't wet that
out west though
it's a joke I was just joking
Once Upon a Time
Three Little Pigs
first Pig
builds his house out of straw
big bad wolf comes
he says a huff and a puff little pig
little pig let me in blue Pig says now
by the hell am I
right
wolf was like yo
and I'll Puff I'll blow your house down
let me go blow this house down right so
that little pig runs to his other homies
Pig's house right which is made out of
sticks
and
little pig little pig let me in not by
the head on my
the column response to the power of
story
so I just made you do that
why did you do that
right I've been in front of millions of
people
that I've never met before
I had them doing all kinds of things
right consciously unconsciously they
just want to be that's power
be careful rappers
I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll blow
your house down
he helps he Puffs he blows House Down
right
those two little pigs go to the third
Pig's house this house is made out of
no it's made out of a Carbonite material
at least here that mightier would be
made out of that
we made out of nuclear energy or
something like that
um
it's made of bricks
and he knocks Little Pigs Little Pigs
let me in not by the hell my
is
I'm still saying it why
oh dude
Jazzy
no I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll blow
your house down he blows he blows he
blows what happens
repetition break plot structure is what
happened
it was a break in a repetition
right
first Pig did a thing we'll do the thing
the thing happened you're like all right
cool shiny change
right
next thing
pigs do a thing wolf does the thing
happens same thing happens
right go the third one oh
they do a thing they do a thing surprise
nope
can't blow on these bricks
right repetition break plot structure
where have you seen this
we've seen this I know you've seen this
everybody's seen this
you've seen this in rap
verse verse hook
verse
is that really
that you know one two one two one two
just
Maybe
so it's not really a macro
right it's not some that rap macros that
act like that but not really
that happens musically happens in
Beethoven
right training training habituation
habituation Divergence
has the same kind of effect right
training training training
same same different right similarity
similarity Divergence right
um
like the um the verses in Gold Digger
where like the first perspective the guy
who's done with everyone who keeps it as
from the perspective of neural portrays
the original narrator
it's reputation the greatest the
greatest example of that
is this
Stan
right anybody where's anybody not aware
of Stan anybody not not blown away about
his list
don't know what this means
Stan is probably Eminem's uh
greatest record
right arguably hands down probably
Eminem Eminem's greatest record
right
the song is about
a fan is where we get the word stand
from
right anybody got any stands in here
I got a couple stands I got I have a lot
I have a lot I'm a stand of you
yeah I do
I appreciate that there's a Stan
reciprocity going on right here
hey Stand By Me
um the song is about a fan
who writes m m a letter
and he's writing this letter
dear Marshall right he writes a letter
in the first verse
then it goes and he writes a letter in
the third verse
and the second verse I apologize right
writes another letter to Eminem
this one's a little bit more
kind of aggressive you know a little bit
more
yeah you know you owe me something I
bought you know the third verse third
verse isn't a letter per se
it's a recording
and the Stan this fan of Eminem
he's recording himself
kidnapping
in true Eminem Fashion Is God
um
his uh his girlfriend
and doing this weird kind of
murder-suicide plot
and he's recording this thing to Eminem
and then at the end of the verse of the
third verse he comes to the realization
like we're going to drive this car over
this bridge
he's like oh [ __ ] how am I going to send
this out
right
but that's not the plot twist is it for
the stands of Eminem Who know right
that's not the plot twist but that's
great he got to stop right there
but there's a fourth verse
right kind of breaks this to this one
one two structure or this this three is
trifecta this tricolon was like one one
then the twist
he does one one one twist
and the twist is
Eminem
finally receives
the letter
from the first verse
right and he sits down to respond to it
he says Dear Stan
I appreciate that you got all my records
right I'm sorry I couldn't get back to
you I was on tour hey man I hear you
going through a lot hey just you know
chill out you'll be all right
and then Eminem as he gets toward the
end of the verse he said you know
sometimes people do crazy things like
there was this guy who got upset and he
took his car with his girlfriend and he
drove it off a bridge Into the
Wilderness and Eminem has the Epiphany
like oh [ __ ]
it was you
right
the layering and the complexity
right of how he worked
right
that repetition break repetition plot
break structure right masterful
right taking a very simple concept that
we all learned when we were kids
because we all knew China
right
so it's
very very simple macros
right that we've all can
process and all have been
privy to but then how do we turn around
and use that
in our work as rappers
right very basic things instead of
trying to do a bunch of details
right a bunch of word flips and name
flips and multiple syllables
am I rapping it's having a hitting an
end right right okay that's cool
right why don't can you master these
basic things
and then the argument becomes Stan is
one of the highest selling records of
all time
in any genre of music
right to the point where the name of the
song entered into common vernacular
the power of rap
right on par
right
on par culturally with E and E equals MC
squared
right on par
right
and other kind of catchphrases from
different fields science social sciences
archeology whatever you want history
right Stan is right there
right General if ever is a song that I
wrote it's about a little girl
true story and was janayla
she was six months old
she's murdered in Chicago
she was she was shot about six times
the gunman was trying to kill her father
in retaliation
stealing a PlayStation
he didn't know that jenayla was sitting
on the lap
he just ran up to the car and started
shooting
Mr father hit her six times
a six-month-old baby
destroyed the city
right I was like
I need to make that a song right now
and the song was about Janella
growing up
going to school being really smart
going to school going to med school
becoming a doctor
instead of going to work at let's just
call it
I don't know MGH
or whatever the hospital is
um
she goes to open up a free clinic
in the neighborhood in which she grew up
in
and then one day she's in the office she
hears some gunshots outside
and then she runs outside
to this van
and gets this little girl
triages her stabilizes her
to the paramedics can come and
eventually see you saved saves a little
girl
she doesn't realize that she just saved
herself
right
repetition repetition
The Twist the power of that the surprise
all surprises don't have to be good
surprises they can happen in they call
it valence it could be somewhat sad
right it doesn't have to be but a little
glimmer of hope
in there
doesn't change the situation but it's
cathartic it helps
yeah
Sing About Me Kendrick Lamar
me to me one of his his greatest record
just the first verse
where he's singing about a guy wrapping
him out of God
who's in the streets
and was involved in some violence
and he does it a different way
so I reveal I say it I reveal it you
know you bet you didn't know you didn't
you just saved yourself
Eminem reveals it the words he says oh
oh [ __ ] it it was you
Kendrick and his genius
he he's writing a letter in the in the
person in this as he as if he's this God
and he's like hey if you're if I live to
see your album come out
you just did a series of gunshots then
the verse stops the beat keeps going
so God he dies
right if I live to see her I'm coming I
just want you to do
right repetition break structure in the
class we study this
right we'll take examples
we'll set up a theme we'll say okay
we're going to talk about surprise we're
going to talk about a very specific type
of surprise on how to utilize it and
execute it and we'll use this particular
frame right we'll start with three
little pigs and then we'll end on
Kendrick Lamar right and show you
different ways to navigate and assess
and then hopefully accomplish that
process in your own work
you can talk about whatever you want
you talk about three little pigs if you
want right so that's the rhyme you know
that's the only thing I ask and it has
to be to a Beat
there's more it's not just surprise
right I call them Primes
because I like to sound smart
mathematical
but fundamental rap primes we just went
through surprisal there's different ways
there's different mechanisms there's
different approaches to generate
surprise
right to navigate through it right to
process it the hope would be the same
way that you did the acronym for rap you
do that for a surprise
right you look at this thing you look at
this word the single word the single
concept and you approach it from all
these different angles and waves to try
and hack it
right come up with new novel surprising
ways to surprise
right maybe it's do it in a group
right do a little Think Tank right do a
little something do figure out different
Avenues to generate that
rhyme is the another one
metaphor
tone
and then etc
etc
etc etc
right and we can do this all day
right all of those very very fundamental
uh very very powerful things that we
interface with on a daily basis are just
kind of sitting dormant in rap
waiting to kind of be explored in a very
methodical very classical way
with the goal of creating new work
right not all work new work I want to
create new work we have to advance some
of these problems or rethink them in
fundamental ways with the new knowledge
or the New Perspectives that you as a
younger generation have
that I don't possess
yeah
yeah
cool
that's the name of the class for uh MIT
undergrads
it is also open to
Harvard
Wellesley and mass art in terms of cross
registration so if you're interested
you're our student of vanilla schools
you know somebody that's in any of those
schools
they're more than welcome to apply
that is the course number special
subject
CMS S60 rap theory in practice
it'll be up on pre it'll be up for
pre-registration tomorrow
actually
um
and then outside of this
one of the
conundrums that me and dakati have been
trying to solve
is making sure that the community of not
only Cambridge but Boston wide and
Beyond those are able to participate in
the course and in the class in some
capacity so the syllabus will be up if
you want to follow along nine times out
of ten we will be working with ocw which
is open courseware here at MIT to at
least record it there's other things
that we're thinking about and primarily
we still want to hold sessions like this
so talks that are open to the public
open open to the to the grad students
open to faculty open to staff anybody
that wants to come in and kind of
address and run through these in a
different way for folks that are
interested in taking a class want to
have a little bit more information you
will be rapping and recording in the
class
your final project is the EP
I will [ __ ] fail you
right I will
I so will fail you
my name is Fiasco so
that is a failure and I have no problem
sharing you
no I don't know but I do want you to
take it seriously
you don't have to know how to rap
I'll teach you
um but you will be expected to rap and
you will have rap assignments that you
have to turn in okay so if you're afraid
or if that's a challenge for you I
cordially invite you so it's a wonderful
experience I've taught this before so I
know it works
um but yeah so that's just a little
information on the class if you're
interested in going through some of
those white papers about surprise
um this is the uh
uh it's a body of papers got the
ubiquity of surprise developments and
Theory conversion evidence and
implications for cognition and it goes
from computational like actual computer
science all the way to cognitive theory
it's a basic more even more kind of
theories and applications a way to
approach a prize and it's in a journal
called topics
um which is topics in cognitive science
and it's on online
Wiley library for those who are kind of
astute but you you better if you're
looking for it that is the uh the bundle
of papers if you want to continue on
yes
there is an ER tournament
I uh I play er there's a few other
people who play her in this room maybe
you don't know where her is but now's
your time
to do the thing with the phone maybe
maybe you'll pick it up maybe not or you
can go to player.org it's something we
started here at MIT not too long ago
this Society International the uh it is
the governing body the only governing
body for ER in the world
I did it when I was finishing my
syllabus because I got bored
um and now we're throwing our first
tournament
at the BSU the black student union and a
walker and it is uh Friday five o'clock
it is ten dollars to register
um but there are sponsored slots for the
Brokey brokes
um
and there's a 250 first prize so come
have some fun with us there'll be staff
there it'll be students there's it's a
great we've been playing for a couple
like a month so if you're interested
um there's that
and then thank you appreciate your time
coming out in the weather and the rain
and I hope it added value and I will
leave the balance of the time for
questions or insights or follow-ups or
hate mail which I also will take
confrontations fights you want to throw
hands I'm here for that
um but yeah so appreciate you all hope
it uh added value
[Applause]
all right uh I'm back as the Q a bouncer
and wanted direct your attention to the
two microphones we have set up
please come to uh one of these if you
have a question
uh
Mr Fiasco over here will be glad to
address it absolutely
there's uh two mics down here if you
want to pull up this is your chance yeah
[Music]
what made you write the song hip-hop
saved my life
I mean because it did
um
a lot of my friends are dead
um
so
me it did
you know
um
I'm sure
that I would have survived
you know
but it preserved a life that I wanted to
lead
right because of multiple lives we leave
we lead a different life every day
multiple lives in a day right but which
life do you want to lead the most you
know and Hip-Hop gave me the tools
um and the opportunities
proof is in the pudding
um to live the life that I wanted to
live yeah
um
hip-hop also kills a lot
you know so just weird
dichotomous balance that we're trying to
do
the song itself was was uh uh homage to
Houston Texas though to the rap to the
to the scene the hip-hop scene in
Houston Texas which I was a huge fan of
a huge fan of the uh the artist it's
actually kind of loosely based on the
life of Slim Thug
um and if you see the video you see like
Bambi in there you see a few other cats
from Houston in there
um
and yeah it was it's a it's an homage to
that scene I thought they were
superheroes like when you look at
Houston rappers and they Mouse on Iced
Out the swag the whole I was like oh
these dude like Paul Wall and all those
guys so it was an homage to them but the
message overall was you know it does
save lives if you let it
you know if you wanted to
uh first off I want to say thank you
Lupe for being here and one sharing your
art throughout the years really
appreciate it
um my question is actually regarding
just your philosophy for learning
um I spent a lot of time listening to
your podcast during the pandemic and one
thing I really appreciated was hearing
how you talked about your father and how
he knew just a lot about everything and
I think as someone like you you know a
lot about everything as well too so I
was just curious to hear about your
philosophy for Learning and how you
approach new things each day
um
I mean I love learning man you know I
love it
um we have nothing else to do you know
um part of it is everything materially
that I've ever wanted I had
you know
um everything
experientially to a degree I've
experienced
um
and that's not to like like humble Flex
or anything like that but it's like of
all the only thing left was to learn you
know so I come to school every day I
don't go to college right so this is my
freshman year and I'm treating it like
my freshman year at MIT right and so I
just go to my office every day and read
white papers you know and people come by
and they drop off books they say hey do
you want to go to the lab and I'm in
there just like a freshman just in there
doing Transformations and pipetting [ __ ]
and reading through kind of historical
monographs and all type of other
craziness and I've been doing that since
I was a kid I've been reading this like
when I my sister's legend about me is
that uh I used to just read the
encyclopedia
you know
um and I think even just through rap I
wanted to I want to talk about other
things I don't want to talk about the
same old ribbon Monroe I want to talk
about different things novel things
surprising things and it requires kind
of extending yourself opening yourself
up to other conversations right to other
knowledge bases to other ideologies even
if you disagree with them right and I
look at my track record and I've made
records about nuclear weapons I've made
records about Houston Texas I've made
records about skateboarding I've made
anything that I could you know that
spoke to me I pursued and pursued it
deeply right and even me being at MIT
part of this is like yeah I'm gonna
teach some of the things that I know but
I'm really here learning more than I'm
teaching know because I want to get
deeper into you know surprise you know I
want to get deeper into rhyme I want to
get deeper into Rhythm I want to get
deeper into other things so I'm just
constantly learning never stop learning
right because you don't have a choice
that's the real thing you're always
going to learn
so you might as well be very intentional
about the things that you want to learn
and then be very intentional about how
you want to operationalize and submit
those learnings in your own life yeah so
which idea did you have first the song
the Cool or the album the cool and what
was your inspiration behind it
um the cool started out my mentor was
Cornell West Dr Cornell West and him
Tavis Smiley I want to say uh Dr Dyson
Michael Eric Dyson as well they were
doing like this speaking tour kind of
randomly right
um and I don't know if it's part of like
this the state of Black America it was
something like this very just
interesting it would go to these
theaters and different cities and they
would just sit up there and be smart
right
um and Cornell West said we have to find
a way
to make the things that are harmful
uncool and make the things that you know
are good
cool
and it was like
I gotcha
right
um
and I became the the initial point right
a command was given by one of the elders
you know to the artistic class who spoke
to the youth with a mission to make
those things uncool
and I went right and then the whole
process you might have seen some of it
play out here the whole process of okay
what do we do what is the most
Immortal story
that persists through all culture
right what is that Trope that just never
dies
zombies
right Thriller is one of the biggest
records in the world
and I was like oh zombies
oh yeah zombies
right so I'm going to turn the cool [ __ ]
into a zombie Rotting Flesh
you know like all of those trappings but
I'm gonna do it through a frame so that
it sticks and it stays
right and it's my most popular album
it's my highest selling album
right and so there's something to that
oh yeah being very intentional about
that work and how you do it
um
and then it was just putting other
pieces to it building out the storyline
with the streets and the game and
putting them in a narrative and having
them play against each other and
creating these different ideologies and
then pulling in these different concepts
that are cool a lot of it was uh Miles
Davis the birth of the cool so it's like
he did the birth of the cool I'm gonna
do the death of the cool
I can die right
um so a lot of those decisions are very
intentional to speak to history so that
when questions are asked like that I
could say oh there was a little
influence from Miles Davis birth of the
cool have you ever heard that album
have you
yeah now you're gonna hear it now
yeah so
indeed indeed right learning moments to
help build into your own craft
right but if you don't have that type of
intentionality with how you learn and
how you operationalize the things you
learn then you won't be able to pass
those things along right
um
what's up Ian Mr Professor condry great
talk thank you so much for tonight
um yeah so about surprise uh you know
one thing so interesting about it is it
keeps changing right there's no the old
surprise I was thinking you know back in
the day break dancing look he's spinning
on his head and now it's like oh yeah
it's break dancing and look he's
scratching the record oh my God what's
that and then it's like oh yeah he's
scratching a record are there things
that you've noticed lately and sort of
how hip-hop's evolving and say oh yeah
I thought there was nowhere to go but
now this surprised me or because we're
already used to all this other stuff
like for you what what's a new frontier
for surprise
um
devolving
right there's a de-evolution taking
place
right
um and that's surprising
because hip-hop was all about evolution
right it was all about multiple forms
and that still exists and I want to take
away from that
but it's devolving content-wise or if if
it's not devolving to that degree
it's
super adapted
to the point where it has no other place
to go and it's starting to become
complacent and it's setting itself up to
get overthrown and that is surprising
and so what I look for is what is the
thing that's coming next to disco
hip-hop
right
right Punk got disco out of there a
little bit then like rock and roll and
Hip-Hop kind of got punk out of there
now hip-hop is doing and rap is doing
some of the same things that those
genres which are still there but they're
there calcified
right and they're kind of being pulled
from maybe an electronic music or just
down the third but as a as a genre
leading type thing or a genre in and of
itself where people are still Giorgio
moroder is like I mean he did the Daft
Punk piece but it's like maybe that
counts but it's not everywhere right
but maybe it is we'll have that
conversation later right
um but I feel like that's what's
happening
right I feel like there's there's a
paradigm shift that's about to happen
and that some of that Ultraviolence
right is contributing not only to the
death of the artists themselves but to
the death of the genre
right
um because it's starting it used to be
surprising to hear somebody say I'm
going to kill such and such
right I was like oh my God
he said he was going to kill such and
such did you hear that cut that music
off boy now that is there is no
alternative
and you can't cut the music off
right it can't be that stuck out it's
too it's too democratic
so anyway that's what I think is it is
but in terms of rap itself I really as
you know I really enjoy Japanese hip-hop
um it's always interesting to see the
new artist that come out of these places
where you don't expect it I expect it
because I know the history but it's
still interesting to see how they're
taking the Farms that are coming out in
the new generations and then processing
it right and then given their kind of
cultural spin on it so yeah
appreciate you
yo what's going on boss appreciate you
um for the for tonight
um so I got two questions the first one
is really light it's um it's more so
about the class like what's the process
for a tough student particularly a Tufts
graduate student if they wanted to to
register for this class and then the
second one is um in light of what you
what you kind of discuss it it kind of
like sheds like on the the morphing um
or the appreciation of rap as an art and
a science so what's what's your process
for writing particularly in periods
where you might have like a um a block
of some sort in your writing
um I don't believe there's a such thing
as Rogers block
um there's some we've had some
interesting conversations in Sosa about
that
um some very very interesting
kind of
like there's a physical thing that is
supposed to represent rather that's very
interesting but anyway
um I don't believe in writer's block
um I believe that like there's some
times where you just shouldn't write
I do believe that
I put the pin down my God you know go
experience maybe you take that as a
signal for you need new experiences
right
um
I don't believe I don't necessarily
believe in writer's wife because I have
such a fascination with the base of word
right maybe this is a lesson for you
um If you experience in writer's block
maybe there's something to you asking
that question because you you got right
as well right
um like I fell in love with words
you know in the same way where you can
go back and analyze and assess just
stretching vowels in the same word very
basic things and pull out new meanings
if not new semantic meanings new kind of
structural kind of presentations or new
Sonic ideas that come out of that you
know
um
and just just work with the material
that's there until something comes up of
Interest right that's not necessarily a
block like you're working
right
if if that's what you're doing
right if you're just kind of like keep
trying to throw bars and gather all
these punch lines and be as witty as you
can and you're coming up with weak ass
punchlines
um there are a bunch of weak ass punch
lines you know I come up with silly dumb
punch lines like nope nope no no no no
um but then also come with a little fire
thing here and there but a majority come
up with is Concepts and a ways to
approach a particular concept as opposed
to like I need this bar to be dope
because I want to sound like I'm on URL
with every verse and it's like nah you
know just enjoy words you know enjoy the
feeling that you get when you have a
novel idea and you get that Cascade of
dopamine and it's like oh
lovely right so you got it oh yeah
what's up brother
hey what's up Lupe uh firstly thank you
for coming huge fan
um so I was going to ask you two
questions the first question was just
asked
um
in regards to how do you approach
writing
um you know do you come in with the
freestyle but you just talked about that
so I'll go on to my second question
which was what's your perspective on
redrafting something you've already
written or perhaps something you've
already recorded
um
I mean I draft in real time I edit in
real time right so as I'm writing I'm
editing right
um and there's some things that I won't
depending on what the
the
what I'm writing for
right if I'm just writing for the joy of
writing then that you don't edit because
you're writing for whatever comes out
and you're writing things that feel good
to you right if I'm writing to sell some
records it'll be different right from
writing to going to a battle would be
different if I'm trying to go into
something different
um
there is something to
approaching things
very systematically
right if you have all of this kind of
nascent knowledge there right if you're
coming in within you've been practicing
very intentional things right and then
you can kind of suspend it was a there's
a great uh jazz player by the name of
Bill Evans right jazz pianist right and
he says well you learn all of this kind
of classical training and all these
different core structures and you learn
all this static you know kind of stuff
and very academic and you you go through
these standards and standards and
standards and standards standard
standards so these things become innate
then once they become innate
you can then collapse all that and then
you can create
right freely but you're creating from a
space of Education you know you're
creating from a space of knowledge as
opposed to creating just pure virtuosity
right and so that idea of
build up your basic skill sets
right if you build these muscles then no
matter what you do right you'll be
you'll already have edited your your
synapses would have already kind of
built in certain ways where it's just
been like oh we only do this
so if you build yourself just to don't
do because you can do that you can build
yourself to just do punch lines
right and at the expense of what though
right but you can do that you can build
yours you can build a certain schema set
that only makes this type of writing or
that type of writing
um
but sometimes I do freestyle it out too
right there is a there is something to
just top lining business
I'm gonna get in the back of this place
and show everybody what I can do with my
face I'm a smile on the style and hold
down the island everybody
maybe I'm gonna move into the South
maybe I'm going to do Atlanta
[Music]
um
maybe I'm gonna hit him with the cameras
and scanners and animals right so that's
just like got this top line
just which is just these words but a
feel and then I'm gonna come back and
I'm gonna find the words that match that
but if your vocabulary is this big
you're not gonna do that
right so focus on the basics
Mastery of Basics is mastery period
right
thank you you got it yo
song peace uh thank you for doing this
I'm not an MIT student I'm studying film
at Emerson so the fact that's open to
Public's really cool of you so thank you
um I have another writing question I
think we got a lot of writers in here
but uh all of your albums and songs uh
feel like you build a world and then
fill it with your ideas and thoughts so
do you build a world and then go from
there
and develop an album through that or do
you do it retroactively do you have uh
specific song ideas and individual ideas
you want to express to people and then
build a world going backwards from there
I mean you're always going to build a
world
right you're never not building a world
right or borrowing a world
right and maybe re colonizing different
parts of that world right rarely do I
hear somebody building a world
from scratch I hear a lot of borrowing
of Worlds or invasion of other worlds
right
um so be be cognizant of that
um
but with that said as just kind of like
a general framework like yeah you I I
start with a word
that sounds good
right like
paper tiger
right I'm like oh [ __ ] Paper Tigers
origami
um origami that's Japan oh but that's
also these sharp edges
oh okay what else have sharp edges maybe
that Radiohead album cover for kid a
Amnesia oh then you start to populate
just off that one word right
but you want to start with something
very strong very visible but also maybe
something very mysterious so it can
become a surprising moment for somebody
once you unfold that tiger and you
realize it's the note
That Eminem was writing back to stand
right he didn't know what to do with it
so he folded into a paper tiger and he
put it on thing and it's like oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy little baby it's
not all the songs in the talk together
all right
um so sometimes you build a world
sometimes you borrow somebody else's
world
like how I just borrowed Stan's world
right but now I Incorporated this idea
into it to point it toward this culture
so now we have this type of conversation
right but that other world is still here
so instead of building a world let's
build a universe
right let's build a system
right and that's kind of where I am I
want to build systems interconnected
things
um
but it also depends on what
the project is drill music is Zion I
need to record an album in 24 hours from
scratch
right
the first record is going to decide
or here's the title
cool
it's a little vague but it sounds good
right but it's from The Matrix
so if anything happens we always get the
Matrix right if anything happens that's
from The Matrix Lupi I don't understand
what this means it's just like Pac-Man
or something like this like it's from
The Matrix for the Matrix right
um and then you'd start to just it's a
time thing it's not even about what I
want to do it's what I have to do if I'm
going to meet this
is time limit right kind of like this
talk
um
but yeah so it depends on what I'm
trying to do at that time some some
records take a very long time I'm still
writing this record called Samurai right
which is the life of Amy Winehouse
as a battle rapper right it's like holy
[ __ ] right but it's like right
um
so it's it's a lot of different things a
lot of different ways to go but do you
understand all of them
can you do all of them
right as opposed to being aware of them
and then how many different paths do you
have
at your disposal that's more important
right having multiple paths
yes hey salute my name is Chris what's
up Chris first off late thank you
because uh
uh Food and Liquor was the first album
or what in my household was this first
secular album I bought oh wow thank you
yeah and uh maybe wide in my perspective
on what I perceived to be true and maybe
look into a wider scope you know so
thank you for that for sure because I
learned from Abu gray to
from a gold watch everything that was on
gold watch from learning about what
Heisman body was to I'd be just looking
at the websites so I appreciate you for
that oh you got it you got it but uh
question I got is because
so I remember the Japanese cartoon and
remember Hello Goodbye had a real Punk
feel to it and how early on did bands
like uh I assume Joy Joy Division was
one of your Inspirations yeah yeah Queen
and how early on did that inspire you
and like affect your writing
um punk music is always just
aesthetically we good
okay they're not going to turn the
lights off but our audio visual support
will bounce ends in six minutes okay so
uh we want to see if we can get to as
many questions as possible maybe about
the shapes indeed rather than the
details in the details see how you use
that against me
could you cast that you see how you did
that
always been a fan of punk from a
performative aspect to an aesthetic
aspect right the energy of it the vibe I
based my live shows if not the music
pump Japanese cartoon was my I have a
punk band called Japanese cartoon well I
sing in a British accent it's [ __ ]
hilarious
um
but more for the performative aspect so
my stage shows a lot of that is pulled
from Bad Brains and nerd and you know
Punk and Ian Curtis and like stuff like
that right
um how they performed minimally without
a lot of [ __ ] and we're still able to
put on an energetic show and what does
that take right so that's kind of like
the cue for that and what I kind of
pulled from that genre in a direct way
that you can see right like when I'm on
stage while on the [ __ ] out yeah cool yo
we're gonna cycle through these things
we're gonna get shapes
you know
good evening good evening thank you
maybe I can keep mine brief with an
invitation ah you mentioned earlier how
you can get more of this out there I am
a public school teacher hey just across
the other side of Mass Ave in Arlington
so you can come on over anytime
um because what I was going to ask is
both for the kids and for the teachers
definitely and especially the district
in which I work this is probably not the
type of literature that is embraced so
I'm wondering how to maybe get more
teachers to kind of
cultivate this different type of poetry
in their classroom and also for the
young kids that are dreaming of this
being the next Lupe Fiasco who having no
time to pay attention to my English
class
what message would you give them
um the message I would give to your
English class directly is uh
I'm without 1984.
the book 1984 which I got in my English
class
right there is no Lupe Fiasco right
arguably right because it was like oh
you can tell a story like this and it
has double think
this concept of double thing and in the
end at the back of uh of 1984 there's a
whole dictionary which defines like all
the words that they were using in the
book and it was like a whole like weird
like breakdown of it I was like oh my
God double think oh two ideas operating
at the same time oh man these bars
punchlines metaphors um I need to have
multiple triple entombres double
entender is when I write raps so it
became a teaching moment right so it was
but I had to do that
right nobody nobody said that now that
you know
you can see like what are you interested
in my greatest teacher his name is Mr
Kendrick
Mr K rest in peace
it was like
[ __ ] all this
right I'm gonna just give you this D so
you can pass
so you can focus on what you want to do
right and I'm just here to empower and
Surround what you already are good at
and what you want to do so take this
stuff
right and then how can we apply it to
what you already do
and it's meeting them where they are
right and then for at least for me
humbly I would say so just tell them
like hey man you can rap about this
right
because Lupe Fiasco said so
um appreciate you but I will pay I will
pay a visit yeah absolutely
for sure
hi Lou um so I have a question you
mentioned the repetition break technique
and you listed three songs but I'm
curious if I have the wrong idea about
that because the first thing that came
in my mind is he say she say and the
cool
um because it comes back from the dead
goes back to the people that killed him
I was wondering why that wasn't listed
or if I just have the wrong concept
sometimes I forget my own songs
and I was trying to find the most
obvious examples oh okay
um and and that's why but you're correct
you're correct that that frame is there
sometimes it's there unconsciously you
know because that's just we were taught
to tell stories in a certain way and we
reference the stories that we know the
most and are the most simple right so
but you're correct it is in a cool it's
in it's in other songs as well right and
sometimes it's reversed
right it's about oh how do we reverse
that process what we actually start with
the reveal and then it becomes educate
you after the fact and then you're like
oh [ __ ] that was a giant robot right
kind of deal so yeah thank you thanks
Mars yo
nice to see you again
so keep my question short how do you
think that we like Mig students like
scientists physicists Engineers like
working we contribute to the rap scene
or to the hip-hop music or the culture
say that again
oh what part
like everything okay
so uh what do you think that say us like
MIT students like physicists Engineers
uh mathematicians what can we contribute
oh oh wow wow so one of the best rappers
at MIT right now
is a nuclear physicist bruncino his name
is Alex
all he raps about is nuclear physics
[Music]
right and I'll put him on blast he came
to me he's a grad student he went to
Caltech and then came here for
Grassroots
um
all right docati all he raps about all
of his raps
are about nuclear physics
right and he gets oh my God right but
they're really [ __ ] good
and he can perform them at length he
came and did a five minute thing just
kind of like
and I'm learning and excited and dancing
and going crazy and I was like oh my God
right so
it's how you approach it do you want to
use it as attorney as a learning tool do
you want to you know think about it and
do you want to come up with a mathematic
mathematical formula that represents
this because the other part of these
these uh papers is there is a
mathematical formula for a surprise
right it's like here's this Delta stick
bug thingy with a zoo right and that's
how surprised look it feels a
mathematical equation right and that
exists for everything so maybe the
support would be like hey
take a look at what we do
the same way that you look at
nanoparticles right and what do you see
and then come and have come be in
concert with us and come conversate with
the rappers right and then we can give
you what we see in you and in your field
and how we can say Hey you know if you
talked about it this way or maybe if you
approach it this way you know maybe
people will get it right instead of
saying like you what's what's the thing
uh
you know in in calculus right just say a
little bit of
right just say a little bit of like this
DX over the the that's just saying a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that
[Laughter]
right
um got cool cool be good all right cool
thank you so I gotta tell you this is
going to have to be our last question
but before we take it uh you notice that
we you could hear everything yes that we
were saying so let's let's give it up
audio visually not possible
right
I'll have this one more yeah
the daughter of two professors over here
hey that's why I'm here um I was
wondering I think you have an
interesting point about like how current
state of rap is like you know coming
from devolving there's like a lot of
people again I'm sorry I think you made
like a really interesting point about
how a lot of like current rap is sort of
like devolving like there's a lot of
violence Etc I was wondering if there
are any newer like rappers that you feel
like bring something new to the game and
have been like interesting you
uh new rappers
um
I mean Alex here at MIT raps about
nuclear physics I mean like oh my God
right
like he's ridiculous and amazing and
phenomenal and he's like running a
particle accelerator right now somewhere
and writing raps about that [ __ ] and I'm
like oh my God right when I when I went
out to look at rap and I and this is
something that's going to be relevant in
the class right is
there's rap
music business rap and billboard and the
charts and Spotify and all these other
things that is this much of rap it is
very very tiny reflection of what rap is
and who's doing rap and where
and I try and be tuned into all of it
right and when you tune into all of it
even though that that piece the violence
is there and we can't shy away from that
right all of the other things are there
the ills are there
um but there's also a lot of not you
know I meet a guy who everything he raps
about is nuclear physics I mean another
guy everything and he doesn't even curse
D1 doesn't even curse the his raps at
all which is wild to me you should curse
man
listen it's delicious baby
[Laughter]
um so there's a range and I don't want
to pigeonhole and I also don't want to
just point out
or or limit you to think that what's
available on Spotify on the playlist is
the only thing that you have and the
only thing you have access to right some
of the best rap that you're ever going
to hear is the rap that you go out and
find and discover that you go out when
they're doing an open mic at the Middle
East or they're doing a thing over at
what have you you know or Cambridge
Cipher is doing something or something
like that right like that's where you're
going to see these moments in a context
that'll really speak to you right
because there's something yeah you can
listen to it in the iPod and you can
listen to it in this and listen to it
and add or whatever but there's
something about discovering some random
God you know freestyling on the corner
you know and it's wow the way he
Incorporated what she or they or them or
whomever Incorporated this little thing
and it was like wow that was that was
really good that's rap and it counts
and it's valid right so yeah and buy
more Lupe Fiasco albums he's great I
hear he's I hear I hear that guy's
really good you know maybe maybe not
we'll see but good thank you you're
welcome appreciate the question
um I'll wrap up
I do want to highlight uh my brother D1
here uh stand up D
um
it's it's uh what is it Serendipity or
like it was meant to what's that word
yeah it was serendipitous that's good
right yeah okay cool
um how we arrived here in Cambridge on
the same plane in the not on the same
airplane but in the same time frame with
the same Mission so while I'm here at
MIT doing this uh my brother D1 is a uh
is a Nas fellow down at Harvard
um at the uh uh African-American
Institute right
um with uh skip Gates and the other
folks that are there Professor Morgan
and so he'll be here for the year just
like I'll be here for the year hopefully
we'll be here longer than a year maybe
right dude maybe hey you know hey
hey you know
um
but Dia's down there doing amazing work
researching uh the relationship between
hip-hop and violence hip-hop and
Divinity and all these interesting
layers and Chambers that are of interest
to him and doing it at at the highest
levels is some of the highest and
greatest institutions that America has
to offer so two boys who are been
welcomed into the Cambridge Cambridge
family from our respective cities D is
from New Orleans from Chicago
um on that same mission to kind of show
hip-hop in a different way to show rap
music in a different way and expose it
to you in a different way so just want
to give you your flowers
um and he just released a record called
God and girls too
um which he released not on streams
to your point right it's not on streams
right you go to his website it's you can
download it for free or you can
pay five thousand dollars for it because
he's a
baby stop it stop lying man stop lying
name your own price and then he's also
doing more things at Harvard next
semester and stuff like that so make
sure you tune in to my brother D1 um uh
so yeah
uh lastly thank you again audio visual
thank you guys
um for hanging in there for us we
appreciate it thanks to the staff here
at MIT thanks to all the faculty for
showing up really appreciate you
um and we'll see you all next
we'll see you all uh
Friday at the ER tournament over at
Walker pull up but we'll see you next
time hopefully we'll have another
Symposium like this and if you see it
for the students for the students that
are here I have office hours all the
time I'm in building 14 on the fourth
floor so if you want to come kick the
[ __ ] you want to come play Early you
want to come play some of your music for
me you want to come talk about nuclear
physics give me a book or anything like
that I am available at service to you
here as long as my tenure lasts okay so
appreciate y'all enjoy the uh the
evening try not to get wet and we'll see
you next time thank you